all right let's get into the mailbag one
day early because of our slightly
different schedule this week you can
email info davidpakman.com if you have
an email question comment concern
many such examples for you today
starting with someone who's just very
very angry and i think probably has a
lot more going on personally than maybe
they mentioned in this email nathan
wrote in and nathan wrote you lie about
trump because you have no fact checking
why do you make money off your lies so
you support everything trump is for he
at least kept us safe put da's in charge
to convict drug dealers that bring car
fentanyl into our country should be
executed they are killing innocent
people knowingly that was one sentence
you want to be a true podcaster have me
as another podcaster that is debatable
to you on live every time you're on
having a podcast
even though he's not the best at the
truth necessarily you think biden has
told one truth or been transparent
nope he said he is a middle-of-the-road
democrat
turns out he's a bigger socialist than
bernie stop hating usa and start acting
like you live in america because either
go back to where you were and live there
or support the country you live in now
gas food crime etc what's wrong with you
at least trump can hold a speech without
forgetting where he is what he's
speaking about and understand what the
heck he is saying
support our country your standing in
these are all the wrong your by the way
you're a microphone warrior couldn't
stand up for usa troops and look at all
the problems this country has right now
just be a human not and not a dem
liberal for a minute
i'm not a republican and you're calling
republicans dumb and stupid and nuts etc
what's the matter with you
i'm bored watching you say trump's board
is pathetic what's better than trump
rally you're making your dime off his
fantasies i don't see you covering joe
biden anything
you're impressive to want a crime-ridden
president that has not kept one single
promise and trump kept all and some
email me if you want to debate you on
your podcasts i'm definitely getting
into this line of work now that i see
your pathetic lies if i have time which
i will make time
you don't care that you're deciding to
only like half the country or more
actually with all your side coming to
the republican side and i am not
necessarily a republican but versus
biden i am he's terrible
hope you get brighter wishing you the
best
from the middle
of the road
that is apparently not a republican
but an enlightened centrist of some kind
presented with no further comment
because
i feel like i have a brain injury when i
read it greg wrote in about motive
greg said if trump stole classified
documents from the white house what
would his motive have been for
committing this crime it's a valid
question
there have been many cases of people
stealing classified government documents
do you think there's a simple
explanation like the others did he plan
to make money by selling the documents
to russia that's greg from costa rica
this is
a great question to which i have not
heard a satisfactory answer what did
trump plan to do with those documents
what did he plan to do and certainly you
know we could speculate about what greg
is writing here
but i just don't have the answer
and with trump the real answer could be
anything if you think you have an idea
what trump planned to do with the
documents
let me know because i have no clue
steve wrote in
i am so sick of hearing about the fbi
searching trump's place
being unprecedented who cares
how does something become
precedented it has to happen for a first
time at some point right the level of
sheer ignorance is beyond belief yeah
i've talked about this the fact that
this has not happened to a president
before tells us nothing about whether
it's the right or wrong thing to do
whether it's legal or illegal and
whether or not trump is a criminal
everything happens for the first time
sometime everything that has happened
at some point was happening for the
first time
and what certainly is unprecedented
is a president that did all the things
that trump did and flouted every norm
rule and apparently even some laws
so
steve is absolutely right this entire
they've never done this to a president
before thing and therefore it must be
wrong
is logically fallacious and it certainly
doesn't pass the sniff test
next email is from lisa lisa wrote in
about the secret service in mar-a-lago
and says david is it possible that if in
fact the fbi found nothing and donald
trump safe that perhaps he was
forewarned by his loyal secret service
agents that contents of his safe were
wanted what are your thoughts yeah you
know on the night of the raid the of the
search warrant being executed i'm trying
to be more accurate about that
eric trump went on tv on fox news we
covered it live
and said there was nothing in the safe
now
he may have simply been lying
but if it's true that there was nothing
in the safe
i would immediately start wondering
whether the documents were just moved i
mean it's just a completely natural
obvious question to ask
and
clearly
any investigator worth their salt like
the fbi has many of
would realize that so we don't even know
if it's true that the safe was empty
since then everybody stopped talking
about the safe was empty so it might
have been yet another lie just told on
the day of but of course if the safe is
empty
who might have warned trump and where
did they move the documents is a
perfectly reasonable question to ask
brandon wrote in about kinzinger for
president
uh kinzinger being the retiring
republican congressman adam kinzinger
who is not a pro-trump republican
brandon says dear sir as i discussed as
discussed in one of your recent shows
the democrats offer slim pickings for a
presidential candidate in the event that
biden doesn't run what about adam
kinzinger what better democrat to beat
trump or desantis than a republican's
antidote no so first of all i haven't
said that there are slim pickens i think
that there are great people
in the democratic party they aren't the
uber progressives but there are some
really good politicians in the
democratic party people are talking now
about gavin newsom i i'm not like a fan
of gavin newsom but i recognize he's a
very skilled politician i think pete
edge edge would crush anybody in
one-on-one debates the way he's crushed
his fox news appearances i think jamie
raskin is fantastic i think john ossoff
is a guy with a bright future stacey
abrams is interesting to me i i don't
think it's slim pickens on the
democratic side that's number one number
two
there are plenty of actual democrats to
choose from
i don't see why we would go with the
retiring republican
for the democratic nominee doesn't it
just doesn't make any sense to me so i
get what you're saying brandon maybe
republicans would say hey look here's a
republican but he's running as a
democrat i'll vote for him it sounds
muddled and it doesn't sound like a good
idea
trina wrote in and trina says about
right-wing trolls versus left-wing
trolls sir after seeing the beautiful
message you received containing all
those f-bombs i started to wonder how
often that happens on the other side
admittedly i don't follow many
right-wing accounts but it seems the
ratio of right-wingers trolling
left-wingers would be exponentially
larger than that of left-wingers
engaging in the same behavior i suppose
it would make sense as the right seems
far more likely to commit violence based
on political ideology but i'm curious
nonetheless are you aware of any
reputable studies on this topic
thanks for continuing to tell the truth
each day no matter who trolls you so i
don't have any studies that i was able
to find
about whether left versus right wing
trolling
of right versus left-wing content
creators
empirically has been has been quantified
i i don't know about that i can only
speak to the stuff i receive what i can
tell you is that when you look at
propensity to violence politically
motivated violence in the united states
is almost exclusively right-wing
the right often will deny that they'll
say you're miscategorizing some of it
or what about antripha or whatever else
they come up with but the truth is that
when you look at politically motivated
violence in the united states
um if you want to find it on the left
it's the occasional what's called eco
terrorism
and it's relatively rare
the violence is mostly on the right that
we know for sure
peter wrote in and says how can i
request to be gifted a membership via
the website beautiful question
every week i get 10 emails from people
saying david
please put me on the list for a free
membership and as i've said
probably a hundred times
you can't get on the list by emailing me
you must follow these extraordinarily
simple instructions if you want a free
membership we have a waiting list it
simply goes in order you go to
davidpakman.com
slash free membership
okay peter
davidpakman.com
free membership you will be asked
your name and your email that's all we
need to get you a free membership
we currently have 800 people waiting
i know that sounds like a lot but we've
already gifted over a thousand
memberships so it actually does move
relatively quickly
um
davidpakman.com
free membership do not email me john
wrote in about due process
and john says dear mr pacman i don't
understand how people on the left
cheered about the deaths of bin laden
and al-zawahiri proper procedure would
require that they be captured alive
extradited to the u.s and tried in court
before any punishment could be imposed
no jury has seen any evidence nor heard
any legal arguments in support of any
punishment i feel that we us citizens
have been made party to an extra-legal
assassination of potentially innocent
men so listen potentially innocent i
just don't buy in the court of public
opinion
these these guys were guilty of sin
but i agree with the point about due
process and i've expressed this concern
before and others on the left have as
well
when i say that joe biden has an
accomplishment to his name this year
of
ordering a successful strike against
ayman al-zawahiri i don't say that as if
there's no controversy about the total
lack of due process i've mentioned it
multiple times there's a complete lack
of due process that's absolutely true
and as progressives it is right for us
to be concerned about that and i
recognize
that when you are a most wanted
terrorist
and as a president you're able to take
them out to use course language
um
that it is seen as an accomplishment so
find progressives that don't care about
the due process part but
uh i absolutely care about the due
process part of that
jock wrote in about electric cars and
says hey david i never get tired of the
republican dumb blonde joke marjorie
taylor green her rant against electric
cars was a classic the marketplace is
deciding nobody's forcing anyone to buy
an electric car if all of america
decided to drive a diesel 4x4 pickup it
would be just as bad the price of diesel
fuel would will go way up pollution
would go way up but hey the oil
companies would make even more profits
oh wait the dumb blonde joke is mad
about the price of gas and diesel going
up as the big oil companies gouge poor
silly margaery yeah
i don't know that we need the dumb
blonde stuff um but it is absolutely
true marjorie taylor green last week
tried to make the argument if everybody
wanted an electric car the electrical
grid wouldn't be able to keep up well
everybody can't get an electric car most
of the electric cars on the market have
waiting lists so we know what the
adoption rate could be of electric
vehicles and there's a plan in place for
the electrical grid to in parallel with
that have increased supply the point
jock makes is a really good one
if everybody switched to diesel cars
there wouldn't be enough diesel and
diesel would be astronomically priced
absolutely correct and the vendetta that
some of these people seem to have elect
against electric vehicles much of it
comes from ignorance
and it comes from political bias they're
just it sounds like a sort of green new
deal what aoc has a tesla it must be bad
and
it's mostly ignorance and confusion and
actually i would say ignorance and
confusion is sort of the theme of people
like marjorie taylor green info
davidpakman.com with your questions
comments and concerns
we will see you on the bonus show
momentarily